hey guys how's it going so right now I
am packing for Australia I am heading
out there with call of duty because the
colony championships is happening at the
end of March so we're gonna be doing
some player interviews I'm actually not
sure all of what we're gonna be doing
out there so stay tuned because
obviously I'll be vlogging my travels I
need to pack because I'm leaving here in
an hour and I actually have not packed
at all Francesca's coming with me and of
course she will be here at 6:30 and she
will probably be here a half hour early
because she's always very prompt
so my luck not ready my house is a
disaster everything is everywhere I got
it back Oh benadryl
got it dinner oh great neither holy moly
I don't think so
so the time right now is 646 p.m. and
what time is that in Sydney Australia
only 46 p.m. Oh tomorrow I probably
should have looked at the itinerary
before I left I was like I didn't know
what airliner flying I was thinking was
Virgin Atlantic and I'm equip or go to
Australia oh it's Virgin Australia
you guys are never gonna believe this
but I already lost my boarding pass and
we haven't even taken off yet I'm
actually getting a little printed there
Chester ran back out this piece you
could find it like are you kidding me
and don't even know how it happened I
hope this is the guy said it was a good
omen I'm hoping this is that esteem last
already passed within
not even 36 so not even a minute no
that's it and we found it on the ground
823 meme it's the airport you know only
a one small little casualty of my
boarding pass we're getting some burgers
and then we're gonna be boarding walk up
members of our partner rooms so see you
guys in two hours got the benadryl
hopefully this will make me okay alright
guys there goes our I will is now 15
there were still hours were here we made
it maybe the customs we've landed and
now we're calling an uber because that's
what you do in a foreign country you
call uber
[Music]
we just had our first lunch and it was
actually it was breakfast but we are
officially here and one thing that I've
noticed so far is that the Americas
poppin absolute where we going just came
in okay was poppy everywhere
take another another few steps more
coffee shops this is so fabulous I'm
really looking forward to changing my
clothes I mean we just we flew and I'm
dirty dirt
[Music]
thanks for watching the first day in
Australia I'm not really sure what we
did all I know is I'm super jet lag say
June pretty - see you later
[Music]